hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of the grand Chester's
your next move rapid tournament in
Leuven this is the final round of the
rapids and tomorrow and the day after
tomorrow we're gonna have a blitz day
nine rounds of blitz tomorrow and nine
runs of blitz the day after tomorrow so
gonna be wild two days which you know
I'm gonna try and cover cover most of
the tournament at least show those games
that were interesting but there is a
festival a three-day festival going on
in my hometown here so you know I'm
gonna have to visit visit the festival a
little bit you know there there is a
nice craft beer day and everything so
we'll see how much I will manage but
I'll try to manage at least the
important ones so getting back to this
game it's a very nice game and if I we
definitely didn't have the greatest
tournament so far and it seems like this
entire tournament I'm only showing
fabi's games but you know the games that
he played either winning or losing were
very interesting so it's it's not my
fault here he faces Sergey Karjakin in
the last round who definitely in the
last round of the rapids who had an
excellent tournament so far and he has
the white piece so not an easy task
before we check out the game we do have
a very nice photo challenge not gonna be
an easy one this time so once again best
of luck to you and let's have it so here
it is who is this very nice gentleman I
believe most of you should know him
those of you that don't I will give you
a little hint in 1976 he defeated in
Manila and none other than Anatoly
Karpov those of you that have been
following my channel for quite some time
now might might even remember seeing
that game on my channel if you haven't
seen that game you're welcome to check
it out but before you can check it out
first you have to figure out who this
person is
so best of luck to you and if you
haven't do check out that game it's
quite a masterpiece so let's check it
out
Corrigan has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have E 5 9 2 a 3 and
now Fabi does go for his betrothed
Knight to f6 Knight captures we have the
classical variation of the 6 Knight to
f3
captures now see for the kauffman attack
against the Petrov defense Knight to c6
we have d4 d5 and c5 now a variation
that you will not very often see in
classical time format so once again you
know once again it's very nice to take a
break from the classical time format
from time to time
hence the Corp of quote above the board
Bishop to e7 now we have Bishop to b5
castles and now kurakin castles as well
fob because Bishop to g4 with the simple
threat of simply capturing the knight on
f3 and then grabbing the pawn on d4 or
simply grabbing the pawn not immediately
but you know and then I just pin so you
do have to take care of this
so Bishop captures on c6 b captures on
c6 and now h3 either forcing the bishop
to capture the night which you know you
never kind of want to do don't want to
give up the bishop pair so Bishop to h5
and now yes you're still not out of the
woods
this Knight is stopping you you can't
really move the Queen you have to play
something like Knight bTW - but then
you're gonna play a passive game
hurricane decides to play an active game
and he goes for g4 immediately unpinning
Bishop to g6 and now Knight to e5
forcing to grab the threatening to
capture the bishop but also threatening
the c6 pawn and the only way to actually
defend the c6 pawn would be Queen to e8
but that's not the kind of move you want
to make the your position would simply
be silly would black here so after
Knight to e5 Bishop to f6 either either
gonna capture the night or the night now
has an option either he will capture on
g6 which definitely a lot of people
would do but Cara can seize the
opportunity to grab a pawn and he rubs
upon so Knight captures on c6 Queen d7
attacking the knight we have Knight back
to b4 and now rook a to b8 so still so
that's 1 2 3 so a bishop a Queen and the
rook developed for the price of this one
point not sure if that you know double
spawn was worth it Knight back to c2 and
now
to h4 already pressuring h2 and if you
look at blacks pieces and now if you
look at whites pieces it's hard to say
if that point was was worth it
we have f3 attacking the night 993
attacking the rook rook to f2 and now f5
Bobby is going for the kill
Knight to c3 and now nice to e4 opening
up a discovered attack from the bishop
to the rook so what do you do here here
moving the rook is definitely the way to
go
rook to f1 is an option here a kurakin
goes for rook to h2 Knight captures and
c3b captures on c3 and now rook beat
back to e8 going for rapid development
now all of Bobby's pieces are in
excellent excellent squares after f5 is
pushed this bishop will come alive and
it will be a very nice position for
black Bishop to d2 and now brush up to
g3 rook to G 2 and F force solidifying
that Bishop on g3 and really restricting
the movement of White's pieces rip the
c1 this Knight is under attack by the
bishop this Knight doesn't really have a
good square to go to you can't really
move the Queen as you're gonna lose the
knight so look c1 defending the knight
not preparing to move the Queen but now
comes a very nice move Bishop to d3 not
allowing this Queen to move anywhere
Queen to f1 was an option but not
anymore
we have 91 attacking the bishop Bishop
c4 and now Queen to c2 and now another
very nice restricting move Bishop to e2
and now there's really nothing for what
you do here other than wait
the threat of course is Bishop captures
night and night is the only piece that's
defending the f3 pawn and then Bishop
captures on f3 so there's really nothing
you can do to stop this here Kirk in
place c4
we have pawn captures on c4 and now
Bishop to c3 at least trying to activate
a little by giving back some material
but now Bishop captures Sonny one rook
captures and Bishop captures on f3 rook
captures Queen captures and now rope to
f2 attacking the bishop bishop to d5 and
Queen to e2 offering a trade of Queens
here Bobby declines the trade he plays
queen
to g6 as he is he controls a lot more
space when you control more space you
don't want to trade Queens or pieces for
that matter this Bishop is an excellent
piece slicing all the way to h1 in the
future ideas like queen bee 1 check
could be possible fall by Queen to h1 if
this rook ever moves for example so a
lot of things to consider here here
Queen to e5 a very active Square for the
Queen although the Queen cannot really
stay there
we have c6 defending the bishop on d5
and now the Queen
it is a nice square for the Queen but
Queen to d3 is coming so you don't want
to stop this by playing Queen to e2 but
even with a move like Queen to e2
there's very little white can do here
here
Fabi Carter can try the King to h2 but
now comes the punisher Fabi immediately
plays Queen to d3 and now there are
simply too many threats Queen to g3 with
Czech picking up the rook is a threat
Queen captures Bishop is the immediate
threat so you can't stop both so rook
captures on a four by kurakin giving up
a piece Queen to c2 check first
now King g3 and now Queen captures on c3
with check King to h4 and now rook
captures on f4 Queen captures on f4 and
h6h 6 this is move 38 and after playing
h6 Sergey kirkin decided to resign the
game he's down a piece there's really
nothing to do here any slow move will be
met with g5 winning the Queen and the
game whatever you do if you put g5
ourselves and simply captures captures
captures and there's really nothing to
do here for white so a wonderful game
but Fabiano corona who you know so far
in this entire tournament he's been like
a punching bag
I really had a couple of terrible games
you know he himself said in an interview
that some of the games were even
embarrassing but you know yeah you can't
really help it so this is why I use this
title dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde so as they
said in the live coverage you never know
who we were gonna get in classical time
for me you know you were gonna get but
in rapid he really had a bad tournament
and then
he crushes correctly using a Petrov
defense and Kirkland was having an
excellent tournament so far so let's
check out the standings after the last
round after the last round the rapids
here are the standings Wesley Wesley so
still in first place without a single
loss with five wins and four draws then
followed there's a tie between Lebanon
and Maxim beshallach Rob then follows
Sergei Kirk in Hikaru Nakamura then ma
media of Gouda shook Caruana
Island and onigiri it's also one of the
things he called Nakamura said in an
interview he said that although Wesley
is having an excellent tournament so far
that Nakamura doesn't think that Wesley
will do so good in the blade section and
that well he himself and the some of the
other players will you know catch up to
him and overtake him in the blitz
section and then they have asked Fabi
the same question and then Bobby said
that he doesn't agree with Nakamura that
Wesley is an excellent blitz player
which he proved by winning the Norway
blitz blitz tournament ulti box a couple
of a couple of weeks ago and you know
he's an excellent Blues player and that
Fabi said that he's not sure but he
thinks that he is high rated in which
Dan Nakamura so yeah also an interesting
question what do you think how will
Wesley do in the blitz section and it's
interesting that last year he also was
in the lead two points in the lead ahead
of Magnus Carlsen after the rapid
section but then after after two days of
blitz it was actually Magnus Carlsen in
the first place but there is no caution
in the race this time so we'll see how
it goes
and you know I hope I will be able to
cover some of the games you know due to
the festival going on in my hometown so
yeah I would like to thank all over the
floor and for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video so your thing
called for watching and I will see you
soon probably with a couple of blitz
games and I think if if there will be
time I will continue the uncrossing
series if not then we'll finish the
Louvin tournament and then proceed with
the the cost and Anand series because we
don't really need a lot of time to think
that series so yeah thank you and I'll
see you soon